this is a production of Cornell
University so I wanted to start by
acknowledging and and and thanking Yoga
nation we're on the ancestral homelands
of the Titan nation and I want to thank
them for their their stewardship of the
land and and especially with this talk
being about about traditional ecological
knowledge it's it's especially important
but but it's I think it's important for
all of us to think so I also wanted to
acknowledge several people who have
worked with me
these are primarily graduate students
Adolfo Chung Keane is actually from a
village of luck and Hutchence a yob
which will be featured and some of the
things I'm going to talk about but Eli
are no Austin Arrington Jessica bond
Evelyn bungee Tomac Paco ski who's also
here Eugene who's here is a is Martinez
and Danny Rio Minh and John Sagar there
their work is going to be part of this
presentation and and I of course as we
all know couldn't do most of the things
that we do without this you know the
engines of our of our work and and and
you know and actually the chassis in
that everything really about work not
just not just the engine since it's the
dirty oily parts of really the shiny
wonderful things that we see as well so
and people we see so I'm going to talk
about traditional ecological knowledge
and and what we learned from Tek
specifically for Agri ecosystem design
and then so what how my TK guide are our
designs of Agri ecosystem is something
I've been thinking about for a long time
and the folks that I mentioned before
last 10 years or so just thinking about
traditional ecological knowledge so I
started as Eugene mentioned it's looking
at Echo ecological engineering and I was
working in Honduras on constructed
wetlands for wastewater treatment that
was my Master's work and I know the
ecological engineering I don't know
folks I know it's a design of ecosystems
for the mutual benefit of humans in the
environment
humans are hardly environment at apart
from the environment human engineering
is supplementary rather than primary and
and I was just I was fascinated with
this as a way of looking at how we can
fix a lot of the problems particularly
in lesser developed areas of the world
because the natural system low energy
system and and but when I was doing my
Master's I wandered of place called
novel home Institute it's give me a
little bit of background here and said
it's a place in Chiapas Mexico and
southern most state of Mexico in san
cristobal de las casas and and and there
I saw a movie about the lock and Oh Maya
and it was this indigenous group living
in the rainforest and and growing
rainforest and I was like you know
anthropologists had looked at it a
little bit and I was like wow you know
that's psychological engineering and
it's so much better and more complex at
least more complex than anything I was
learning about in in books and reading
in in in in the scientific journals and
so as I I want to I want to learn about
I want to learn from Ben and Hans like I
want to do that for my my PhD and so as
I it's okay so they don't speak Spanish
I was just learning Spanish at the time
so I could do my project work in in
Honduras inside okay so I learned
Yucatec Maya it was another it language
because I was taught at University of
North Carolina what wasn't taught that
there was a linguist who knew it so he
taught me Yucatec Maya so that I could
learn like Indo Maya so then I could
work with the blackened dome Maya in a
village in Chiapas Mexico and so that
took me a long time and actually went
and worked as an environmental
consultant in between and and and and
and then I you know started and I would
think about the the ancient Maya you
know you think about the age of are just
going to be a sense they ancient Maya
you know you think about these folks
there you know with the temples and and
and and and this this traditional was
ancient culture with it and and these
migrations from that and the fall of the
Maya but actually the Maya ok Maya is
about 65 55 65 ethnic groups in in
Mesoamerica and their whole groups but
60% of the population of Mesoamerica is
Maya right and so I was gonna learn
about the luck and oh my but keep that
in the back of your mind that they're
actually a lot of other folks living in
in this area who might know a lot about
ecosystems and so so I from this I
started to think about traditional
ecological knowledge you know all these
folks living with the land putting on
the land living from the land and that
gives some a very intimate understanding
of that of that ecosystem so the folks I
saw in a movie we're doing that that
maybe other folks were and they work
with limited resources and so maybe
there's something we can learn from
traditional ecological knowledge when we
have resources that are diminishing and
maybe when we have things like climate
change happening right and so I started
to
to think about so think about that
definition of traditional ecological
knowledge
and over the years I've started to
realize that there are several things
that we can learn from from traditional
ecological knowledge at least what I've
learned from traditional ecologic
collage looking a lot of different
systems at this point so natural systems
are complex but design about that folks
have been designing systems for a very
very long time and they've been doing in
in a very very complex manner so I was
looking at constructed wetlands and
think about what that was also cool but
then I saw a group that was which I'm
going to tell you about more so don't
feel like I am going to talk about um so
and then natural elements like stress
events a succession are important now
many of you are agricultural so you
think about your stress events on the
farm something sometimes things you
don't want to have in there but maybe
some stress events are valuable
important for change and then Foods
everywhere invaluable
you know this your Agri ecologist right
couscous and Agri colleges in the room
okay it's not all of your agriculture
okay so I'll change the tote or some of
you like it what are you are you like
what are you like what do you call what
do you call yourself that's not in anger
ecologist give me a sense of who the
audience's soil science what else what
soil scientists ok wait up okay so did
there you know still kind of natural so
I just want to get a sense okay but so
food is everywhere invaluable okay but
we think about it in the United States
like food in the anchor ecosystem I'm
talking about everywhere right so foods
not here but maybe it should be in this
room even maybe along the edge there
okay so foods everywhere invalid
wildlife is everywhere in and valuable
in traditional and connection the place
is critical connection place like in
your system in your AG or ecosystem
connection to place well maybe that's
important maybe that's critical for
traditional ecological knowledge so
natural systems are complex so I like I
said I was working in Chiapas Mexico
which is the
southernmost state of Mexico with the
lacan Don Maya and and and this is
locking Hutchins say yeah but village
that I started working with and working
in the LA condone rainforest there's
Guatemala Chiapas and in this village of
about four hundred people live in in
lacking hi Chauncy AB and and Here I am
starting out my doctoral research with
with with with Jorge Paniagua and
chinook and and in this is a traditional
address of the luck and oh my account
looks like a long hospital gown almost
but it it it's traditionally this out is
actually made out of the bark of a tree
like a pound the bark of the tree so
it's made from from nature itself even
what books are wearing this one is
actually made of and then folks live
within the ecosystem so they're part of
that ecosystem not apart from the
ecosystem so very much like what I was
thinking about with ecological
engineering and they had this very very
complex form of Agri forestry so this is
this is um this is Agri forestry in time
so you have a core which is the first
successional stage and so this is a poly
culture of around 60 or so different
plants then you have a Roby herb and a
hood of che and these are these are this
is this is a shrub stasis in the later
shrub stage and then you have a pock
check or two Mahan may am a handshake
now now Tomek I've been working with
Tomac and and we've divided out pocket
Courtemanche antutu at the time when I
first did it I didn't include pachikuri
which literally means planted tree Milka
or plant a tree polyculture and that
lasts about 20 years that's that's the
that's the first secondary forest stage
and this is a later secondary forest
stage and then you have a fire and you
might have a fire at different stages in
the system and then you want what's
called the Tom J which is a conserved
forest so they have area cycling around
so you might have different air so
you're looking in space
so this is like you might have time T
over here and a puck check over here in
the court so you have a polyculture you
have a you have a a secondary four stage
a later secondary forest stage a shrub
stage they're going at different times
each one of these stages is productive
and so in 40 years or so they might
cycle around and so they grow rain
forest right and and and and and they're
harvesting and using every phase of this
of the stage this is complex ecological
engineering
and and so I looked more and more and
you look at the at the soil you all know
soil scientists do Co all organic matter
and and and so nitrogen increasing over
over time by the time that the new
coucher the tomte which is the by the
time of the advanced secondary forests
it's similar soil at least in soil
nitrogen and inorganic matter we
actually looked at nutrients and we
looked at phosphorus and and looked at
nematodes saw similarities between these
these actually statistically equivalent
indistinguishable with these advanced
secondary forests and and and the
primary force so you see systems that
are
are developing and their philippine
rapidly you see if you just let it go
literature is showing as much as twice
as as can take in that particular area
can take nearly twice as long for the
for the system to develop in some cases
okay and then you look at these at these
systems and so woody species richness
you look at the first successional stage
going up to the six successional stage
what do you see between the fourth and
the sixth successional stages by the
time you get to early secondary forests
your woody species richness is
essentially identical to the primary
force so not growing stands of pine here
they're growing a diverse rainforest
right at least that's the plan
that's the design so so you know it
seems like there's a lot that we can
learn from that and so i was like well
the dist lacking high chance to yeah is
it just the lacking Domeier i was like
well let me look and so i started
working with the Yucatec Maya community
eats in my community mocha in my
community so till Maya and I've since
worked with other communities looking at
these agroforestry systems their
traditional systems this traditional
ecological knowledge to kind of get a
sense of what's going on and one of the
things that I've an addition to seeing a
lot of complexity I talked about design
in these different places like and oh my
Yucatec by a couple of Yucatec Maya
there's an open mind you see it in other
communities as well there's certain
species that they're using to restore
soil so they now they're different
species in some cases but
think about that is this is what we're
gonna plant here what we're gonna leave
here so the soil regenerates more
rapidly and some of them are planted and
some of them are left and and and one of
the species this is this is a chroma
pyramid dolly you see these a lot of
leaf litter and so we tried to figure
out mechanisms associated with that and
looks like you see leaf litter with
distance from the tree and of course it
goes down this is this is
logarithmically and the nematodes
actually went up with distance away from
the tree so that seems like
counterintuitive seems like where you'd
have leaf Lurie to have more nematodes
right the soil of the round worms in the
soil and so starting to think about this
particular species maybe inhibiting
degradation and there's another species
in there piperidine boom and paper doom
comb if you look at the list here and
and and Piper ream tomb has safrole in
the in the leaves which has a societal
toxin so maybe there's some sort of
slowing down of degradation that folks
are using and and we've looked at some
other species and it's it's it's hard to
see the mechanisms exactly is it might
be different functions of different
species and and and maybe not all luck
and oh my err cognizant of all these
these functions but it's definitely
something to consider to think about why
and how are folks designing as they're
designing now about the lock and oh my
and I'm not gonna turn that over time
I've looked at systems not just in
Mesoamerica but throughout the world if
you think about people and their
ecosystems people have traditionally
managed and been part of their
ecosystems for all of the world so this
is actually I've become interested
recently in in vineyards in Portugal so
this is a traditional vineyard system in
in in Portugal and this is a system this
is from 1474 and and in Portugal I don't
know if you can see this but they're
trees and then there
screwing growing up the trees and and
and these systems the the binds are
actually supported on the trees as part
of of the vineyard
and wow that's that's fantastic it
actually comes from from the originally
from the Greeks and then the Etruscans
and then the and then from there to the
Romans and then then from there to
Portugal and and and so I've read that
there's some systems like this in
Portugal and so I was like wow I want to
go look at that and and said that it's
that possible and I need to find out if
there if there are systems like this and
and there are their systems that are in
place right now and what the literature
says as i apophis izing is that these
trees are actually providing some sort
of irrigation through hydraulic
redistribution so they bring enough
water during the day and then and then
dropping at it at at night and and what
the and I had to learn Portuguese too so
I learned a choice so I mean I don't
until I'm I don't speak Portuguese
really well yet but I'm still the
premise were very patient with me and
and and and talked very slowly with me
and and and what it what it looks like
and I did some soil sampling around
these trees and found moisture soils and
what's your soils near the poverty trees
using apologies in coolers
and and then at the same time these
trees which are essentially the fence of
these traditional systems are producing
in a to hectare system with a diverse
poly culture in the middle there they're
producing 1500 liters of wine from their
fence you know I mean that's a really
valuable product that's a that's a
border to this to the system and so so
this is a lot more to look at here until
you look at what you can learn from our
traditional and local aaja commodity
there might be something to learn here
now the European Union is incentivizing
farmers moving away from these systems
so these systems are disappearing right
now because they want the RO system
right well we know you all know what
climate change I mean that the that the
vineyards and wine production globally
is in the state of crisis everything's
moving northward right and so having a
system a natural system that doesn't
require a lot of irrigation right
that's special bringing water up from
from deep zones to manage water and
temperature
that seems valuable and maybe it's maybe
it's not happening maybe maybe it's but
it's definitely worth researching right
it's definitely worth knowing a little
bit more about and so that's so then
natural elements like stress events and
succession are important they're part of
most of these systems right and you look
at so in the block and own system you
have fires and tonics gonna start
working at looking at black carbon in in
these systems a little bit more now how
carbon is a what's happening with the
carbon but at least a little bit of work
that we've done indicates that these
systems might be a carbon sink if the
burn is a low enough temperature I don't
know we've seen we've seen carbon
accumulating at a meter so maybe there's
some carbon that's moving down through
the soil profile from the burn most
swidden systems throughout mexico really
an out throughout the world use fire as
part of a part of a traditional means of
controlling passive controlling weeds of
adding kind of an exchange capacity
there's a lot that's beneficial from the
use of fire potentially right and so
maybe we need to understand that a
little bit better
right now the UN is incentivizing moving
these systems out out of what we do
actually actually giving human these
money to not burn before we know really
what cycling and how it's cycling and so
we need to know more about this right
and this is that this is the from a
recent paper about the luck in don't
mine you see a little bit more
complexity there's an added stage of pic
octa-core in the Mahan che but you see
these succession and systems and so even
even my undergraduate students I ask
them to think about you know how would
you have a successional system instead
to New York no is that possible I mean
that sounds crazy right that's
completely crazy weird where our
instrumentation does not allow us to do
that our machines do not allow us to do
that and no they do not allow us to do
that today
that is trip
well what about 30 years from now
I mean can we start to think about that
we start to think about succession in
the system and what that might that's a
natural process by stopping succession
we have to put in energy succession
happens in ecosystems and that's why
traditional systems throughout the world
use succession you look at the mope on
Mayan Belize
I thought the lacan Domeier system was
pretty cool having having six now seven
successional stages the mopin Mayans
system of beliefs has nine so there's a
lot of complexity in the way people are
managing and thinking about succession
we looked at the zapotec system and a
little bit further north once again you
see succession in the system's food is
everywhere and valuable now working in
agriculture here so so of course we
think about food being everywhere
invaluable but we don't think about it
being you think about being valuable you
market it we grow it we know we need it
right but is it everywhere can we think
about it being everywhere this is the
lack and amaya system these are useful
species and most of them are are useful
I mean they're useful for a lot of
different reason but every signal once
again the successional stages of a lucky
known system the original one them from
their first articles we focus with those
stages and you see 60% of the species in
every successional stage including the
forest stage are useful now this is
talking to people and asking them what's
useful here I can't eat what he went
what can you use for raw materials but
but there's a lot of eating going on in
later successional stages imagine going
into an advanced forest and maybe
there's some other people in it this is
good you going into the secondary forest
and and you know 70% for 70% of species
you can name a use name the name
the species and name a use at least one
use that is a knowledge that's hard for
us okay can anyone in the room do that I
mean that's incredible that that level
of knowledge is and and that level of
knowledge it comes from an intimate
relationship with that ecosystem so food
is everywhere and useful now now we
think about food so I'm talking about um
temporary like over long term long time
right now what about throughout the year
we always think about even in even in
the tropics we think about a you know
harvest season right and that's gonna be
like corn the harvest season who's
worked in the tropics right so so you're
gonna see a harvest season in the in the
north of around August September for
your corn right and that's where and we
see that here here's audist
right here you got a lot of corn there
this is calories so this is once again
I should have a as decided Tomac before
this is some work with Tomac and and and
I worked on and and but look at this
look at this harvest through the year
look at it going from January to January
what do you notice about that harvest
is it just corn no no it's not just corn
right it's throughout the whole year
that people are harvesting they're
harvesting pineapple they're harvesting
yuca they're there they're harvesting
harvesting lots and lots of different
medicinals they're harvesting onions are
harvesting jalapenos that you know beans
I mean it throughout the year you have a
lot of cows you look about the nutrients
it's also regulated throughout the year
so it's a different way of thinking
about even harvest it's it's all the
time it's everywhere it's in the it's in
the forest is everywhere imagine if
there was there was something to harvest
right here and then so I think about it
is it just traditional folks I was in
the Balkans right this was about it was
like almost a whole year ago it seems
like yesterday so I I was in the Balkans
and I was out so you look at this is
street food in the book and so so during
the time of Soviet Union a lot of there
was a lot of food produced in these
large systems right but people did not
stop producing for themselves food was
everywhere and people explain to me it's
like no we never stopped producing at
our home you look throughout the world
people are producing at their home I was
I was walking down the street like this
is the street I was walking on the
street in Albania and I looked at this
end this right here and looked up and
looked up and I was like what is that
and and it was it was a grapevine and it
was that thick and and I like where is
that coming from and looked and it was
it was coming through a wall like so
they built the wall around the grapevine
right like that or they broke a hole
like the grounds coming through let's
just keep on going there were grape
vines growing on gas stations people
were making wine at the gas station you
know it's
just a different ethic but it but it's
give us hope because that ethic which I
say it was a lock and oh my no no it's
most of the world we are abnormal
you
most of the world is thinking like this
right and so we just need to tap into it
a little bit okay so this was that I was
in I was I gave a talk at the Darwin
foundation in last year and about food
and restoration and and and I arrived I
was like you know I want to talk about
food I want to talk about food being
everywhere and so I asked people at the
foundation I asked everyone everyone the
foundation as anyone I met say well what
do you eat here on the Galapagos Islands
that's wild and and I saw I saw the
opuntia everywhere right puntilla is no
Polly's right if he's anyone who's been
in Mexico that's it's that's really nice
fried up and eggs it's really good on
it's like I saw it everywhere and
everyone's like no Kenny anything
Galapagos is is it's a Conservation Area
right
and people were like no no you can't
Kenny and they weren't talking about
it's not permitted they were like oh
those different species of Punky oh
there's no way and um you're gonna get
no the well what about these there's
like great I mean that next wave said
there's a tomato like things I mean can
i no no no that's poisonous everything
was poisoned everything was dangerous
right and and and finally I ran into a
guy named Otto who's who's who's a he's
a ranger right and he's like oh yeah you
can and then I gave my final
presentation after I've done this
research while I was there because I had
a couple of days before my presentation
and and I said well I'll just say you
can eat all this stuff here and um and
then wacho said oh yeah you know what we
stayed alive Rangers have stayed alive
because but we can't we have a different
mindset about what we can eat them what
we can't eat it's it's it's it's it's
phenomenal the it didn't make any sense
to me that a tourist could eat it and I
couldn't right
they're not too different we're not too
different and where the difference is I
understand but there's a lot of
similarities right then wildlife is
everywhere and valuable right
so in our egg root ecosystems it's
valuable this is once again Tomac did
did this work and followed on Jessica
bonds work who I mentioned as well
looking at ya Yucatec Maya system the
birds in these different on the reserves
and in Agra forestry systems and she
found no differences in the atomic went
across successional stage here's a
reference this is the reserves seeing a
similar was statistically young that no
no not distinguishable between the
successional stages and the amount of
species of birds so maybe these systems
are actually valuable to wildlife that
then we started to look at different and
this is once again Tomac is looking at
at these successional stages and seeing
some it changes by successional stage
and by tom che by the later successional
stage or new push j you're starting to
see the reserves and and and and the
birds being being similar milf is much
more dissimilar and then it can kind of
be similarity increases issue as you
grow go through but maybe having this
diversity of lance it adds to overall
diversity of the system so maybe maybe
maybe the systems are in some ways
valuable for for this gamma diversity
right
then we looked at wildlife and I was
talking to folks about in there like oh
yeah well I was talking to Adolfo
chungqing in in luck and I said you know
what climate change we're not too
concerned but there's a dolphin
chunkiness luck and oh my Annie grew up
with his his father's assistant I knew a
lot early on his father died at 101 and
and he was worked with him for the last
ten years of his life every day and so
learned learned a lot about the systems
and he said you know we're not to worry
about climate change because we use
actually the nature to tell us when it's
gonna rain so this is a howler monkey it
makes a call when rain is gonna come
visit chachalaca and and this is the
green lacewing larva and each one of
those so this is going to be changing
coloration this is going to give a call
and and we just did some recent work and
luck and huh looking at the green
lacewing larvae over time in and it's
called Kucha they call it that's the
name it and it literally means carries
water so even the name is associated
with with function right in luck and on
Maya and I'm good thinking you know we
learned like I know my effort something
valuable for something for sure um aside
from communicating with folks I don't
you understand the system so the
coloration change changes and we're
thinking that it has to do with
camouflage so it's changing beat the the
trees will actually change in color as
you go through the year and it gets
green ear and they will say that the
green lacewing will actually change and
get darker and when the rains are gonna
come and so they'll use that to
determine when they're gonna plan and
and they're a bunch of different species
that they're using and we looked at oops
and you see coloration and this is the
average white color and with humidity
and so you see a relationship there
between between the coloration and this
is John Zeiger it's a master student
with me and um and so you see with
humidity and so you've seen these things
that are it seemed valuable and they
they use it turns out I thought it was
just three species they're actually
using about 20 different species to
indicate for them species and halos like
Solar halos when it's going to some
plant some animal when it's gonna rain
and they tell them different things so
this is through the year and so these
different species have different
population patterns and it's that
complexity of understanding that allows
them to determine when to plant that's
that's that's a lot of knowledge
so that's a lot of understanding of
patterns and then okay so I said okay
wildlife important population and that's
valuable and I should say back to
wildlife
you know wildlife are consumed as well
so that wildlife is important for for
you know feeding yourself also it's not
just not just feeding yourself like if
you're corn if you don't plan at the
right time your corn crop and all your
crops will will will die and your family
will suffer but you're also the wildlife
so important for that so then I said
connection to place is critical
something we often don't think about in
terms of design certainly not egg or
ecosystem design but for the lack and
amaya and persistence throughout the
world and I've seen and primarily a blue
board in Mesoamerica be fair i
connection to place is critical it's
really the thing that we need to be
designing for you look at these
different communities here and all of
them talk about their deep relationship
with nature and oftentimes animistic
relationship with nature with nature is
equal to them in terms of value and and
and and that's really common throughout
these these systems you have a daily
relationship
you're gonna value nature that is
important for for conservation too is
worth thinking about conservation well
how do we establish those relationships
but each of these communities all these
places have we want to talk to his talk
to very intimately about the world that
they are a part of and you looked at an
educational system and this is now I've
heard that that that that that that you
all have learned some about energy and
and is that right I say so so this is
not been studying okay so anyway so
energy so you understand the embodied
energy in the system you know this is a
systems diagram and we're looking at
nature coming in to their understanding
of the world and so what what is a
smartinis Tomek and i we looked at we
looked at the value of this traditional
ecological knowledge in terms of the
embodied energy in the system so you
don't have to sin understand this entire
diagram essentially all this stuff flows
into knowledge and we did that comparing
the traditional way of knowing with our
scientific way of knowing right and with
with our Western educational system kind
of looking at literature values and kind
of going back and what we found
who is that there's a very similar
quality if you look at everything that
comes in because you look at and for
traditional ecological knowledge in
local archaeological knowledge your
classroom is the forest and so you've
incorporated all of that stuff and it
goes in and and in addition to that is
when you look at sustainability makers
of metrics like how much renewable
energy goes into the system
these TK systems and le k systems oh
they're so much better than ours because
look at this we're standing on a bunch
of oil
you know look this is all resources with
the lights that everyone
it's everything is all a bunch of bunch
of oil within natural systems you know
in the traditional systems it's not that
way and so if you're looking at
sustainability then maybe and what can
we learn from that well maybe more field
classes maybe we should be doing a lot
of our education outside I mean that
would start to get at it and so that
could be something something valuable
for that ok so I only have like five
more minutes right so how I'd read sure
I can get through this so how might EK
guide accurate edgar ecosystem design
well really it's looking backwards at
everything that that that we've learned
from the other so that we should be
learning from Pekin le KS we're doing an
aggregate system design and we should
allow for succession and stress events
we should ask why can't animals be
everywhere and why can't I can't food be
everywhere and then we want to connect
to place it's the most important thing
and there's just been a few things that
we've looked at so this is a project
that that we at atomic and others worked
on in looking at the lacan dome Maya
system and compared to government forms
of restoration and setting we set up at
a controlled experiment in locking high
chance a yob and really looking at it
over the long term really finding that
that the systems are developing
differently as you might expect
so as you're if you're thinking about
luck and Oh Maya for for restoration for
for Agri ecosystems design yeah they're
developing differently the plant
community is changing that the Latino
Maya system gives people an immediate
harvest and so if you're looking at the
way government does restoration is they
pay communities to plant trees and
do that for a couple years
and and then and then what happens after
a couple years what do you think the
community does I chop it down
they'd put him over there right cuz I
can wait they can't wait 25 years for it
for a mahogany to grow of 30 years 40
years but if you have a lock into Maya
system then maybe you get something all
the way along and so we're looking at
this over the long term and kind of a
measuring plank community and changes
there you allow succession and stress
events so this is worse than some work
that Eugene did looking at different
edible species that were that the
traditional that indigenous groups
around this area work have had just an
addition assumed from this area have
used traditionally for years the ground
not wild sunflower evening primrose in
Jerusalem artichoke and look at that for
restoring a hay field and and and what
what we found was that um that the
harvested plants returned in year two
without seeding so you you're
subtracting seeding from your equation
right and then biomass is very
comparable to what you would have for
the for the hay field and then we did it
with tilling and burning and with the
control and we found that you know there
wasn't much of a difference maybe we can
just let these systems come back without
even preparing too much because they're
the ground that is adapted for here in
Jerusalem artichoke is adapted for here
so maybe we don't have to mess with it
as much as far as land preparation and
that's that's a big savings and you can
correct me if I'm wrong about any of
this more or less right Eugene said I'm
more or less covered and asked why can't
animals be everywhere so so this is
another smaller now really good at
systems diagrams so um there's another
systems diagram this is an agricultural
system so you have renewable resources
that go in you have purchased resources
that go in you have your production
crops you have some soil that that's
that's as harvested and then you have
competing plants and completing
competing animals and what we're doing
with the purchase resources is where
where's preventing success
right that's essentially why we're
spraying right we're preventing
succession we don't want a bunch of
weeds right there bad but and we don't
want everyone to light a cloud of
animals eating our in our crop so we
control for that well that takes a lot
of energy
and and and I'm not saying we want to
want to get rid of that but look at is a
restoration system so now you're now
you're going after plant community an
animal community so those are the two
things you're trying to develop you're
still trying to prevent succession we
still want to control for one particular
species here your cell Breno bereaved
resources and still have Human Resources
you start to have a human community that
come and see this beautiful place that
you've created what about if you're
thinking about animals what do you got
if you combine them and you have a novel
ecosystem based on tea can delicate well
now you all can read this perfectly
right essentially you're getting
cultural and provisioning ecosystem
services by limiting how much you
prevent succession in your system you're
still gonna prevent it you still need
some kind into Rock and oh my prevent
succession maybe they we they do but
they don't do it with the intensity that
we do it and so maybe if you don't move
the intensity maybe that human community
can can gain something from visiting
these Agri ecosystem maybe these agro
ecosystems become places I this was okay
I'm running out of time but I was in I
was in um okay this was in Portugal and
and I was sampling the soil at these at
these at these viticulture system there
were various systems with the trees and
the vines and and it was a traditional
system and I ni and I swear I swear this
happened that I was sampling and this
family was like a whole family came
skipping by me like skipping by me in
the Agrico system in how many times have
you been at a farm and a family has come
skipping by you it doesn't really happen
all that often right but maybe maybe
maybe that's a value
that we're not calculating skipping it's
a high value that's like I mean when you
skip it it was a whole family so okay
then ask why can't food be everywhere
there's some other research Adaline
bungee and I did did we looked at
service berries apples mulberries and
black walnuts in the city of Syracuse
and harvesting from those and how we how
we how we can harness from them right
what's there already not what we planted
just what someone planted a long time
ago and maybe maybe our Agrico system
doesn't have to be just at the farm
maybe there's an apple tree right there
and when you're on break you go and pick
a nap and you eat it or you could just
pick it up bring it home you can do
whatever you want with it you make a pie
with it later whatever you want to do
with that Apple but it's right there
right why can't it be everywhere and so
what we found is that first of all that
there are edibles all over the city of
Syracuse like these are the red dots are
edibles and you see they're everywhere
everywhere and then we also found that
there was a difference in communities so
the poorer communities had fewer edibles
why was that I don't know but they did
and so maybe we should be thinking about
that in terms of urban ecosystem design
seems like the poorer communities are
where you really want to have more
edibles right free food right there
especially in food deserts like a lot of
Syracuse I don't know if you all knew
this but Syracuse is actually for
African Americans and Hispanics actually
the poorest city in the United States
number one and and so you know what
it'll be valuable to have a lot of free
food just everywhere
why can't food be everywhere right it
works in the Balkans you know why can't
we have grape vines growing up our gas
stations I mean I would want to taste
test the grape for sure but why can't we
you know a lot I don't think gas would
go into the grape but I'd like to know
hey you should know that right and then
connect to place it's the most important
thing so how do you do that right well
Marla Emery back to food Marla Emery who
did who works for the Forest Service she
did some research showing that if kids
eat for the environment it connects them
to the environment forever and and that
so maybe that's another reason why food
should be everywhere right because so
kids connect so we've been doing service
projects all around is Onondaga as an
Ida dug a watershed so these are
different service projects a lot of them
are with kids this is actually a series
of rain gardens up and down the creek
walk that we designed as part of an
ecosystem restoration design class that
Eugene was was in and then we end up
redoing it and in the city you know what
we had to redo it when we redid it so
this is eugene installing one of these
rain gardens that's Eugene right there
so um and it's edible rain garden so how
you get people involved and this is
place where people could come by so we
the city loved it so much they're like
hey let's put him bigger rain garden
let's do it and so we came up with
designs and then and they're like yeah
the sustainability coordinate was really
into it and then they came back and they
said you know we've ran it by the
lawyers and we have to take food out
even with education like these are the
berries this is you you that we were
gonna plant you know because that would
be I mean the very few inside we're in
the when I look we're in the tropics
here I mean most of if you caught you
could go out any grass you'd be fine you
know I mean they're very little things
that are poisonous around here um and
yet you know so we had to redesign for a
when we've said it was a what do we call
it
do you remember was it was a smelly
bullring
yes sensory experience we got sweet so
if we had to change that but essentially
we're trying to connect people a place
so it and then this is just an example
is this is the this is a community
garden that we put at the Boys and Girls
Club getting kids involved in the system
getting involved early so what do we
learn here natural systems are complex
for design amol natural elements like
stress events like succession are
important clues everywhere invaluable
well that ever invaluable connection
place is critical and then what do we do
we learn from the tkn le k we allow
succession whenever possible we ask why
can't animals be everywhere asked why
can't food be everywhere we connect the
place it's the most important thing and
[Applause]
[Music]
well you know so Katherine Landis did
some some great work she does finish
your dissertation ideas she didn't look
at the Cayuga she looked at the at the
hood nashoni and they primarily focus on
the Onondaga and and she found a very
different sort of ecosystem looking
historically looking a couple hundred
years ago going forward and what we're
seeing with the locking down system
there's a lot of there's a lot of water
is water-based system a lot of it so you
said the dynamic changes of Onondaga
Lake and so there's a lot of fishing
going on during especially during winter
times who would but then you also saw
the the wetlands and the production of
the wetlands and so was this dynamic
change they would store nuts right and
then they would extract
oils they would they would they would
store you know corn and beans and
squashes as well that would dry things a
lot but but really when I see the
ecosystems that she's talking about and
that you that she found it was this this
this similarly dynamic different sort of
ecosystem I'd say there's a stronger
animal base to it then you're seeing
with the with the lack and own system
and it's definitely more water than
you're seeing with the lucky dog system
I think Cayuga would probably be pretty
similar to that now they she was telling
me that as far as succession goes in
like restarting in succession the
Onondaga they were not using fire
because of course was a very fire
resistant area they were they were
girdling trees but i think an answer to
your question there's a there first of
all I think I think um Katherine the
Katherine's work as some of the first
really serious work about I mean people
have no it's been certain that the other
people's work has been hasn't been
serious but she's really went into into
this system and and and what she saw was
was a lot of wetland management in in
the system so doesn't not a perfect
answer to what what you're saying but I
also live argue that our our landscape
has changed I mean we kids it's gonna be
we are we have structures here
so we can't you can't recreate what
we've what we've got with our farms or
structures as well instead I think and I
think we have to do this with all
systems we have to think about nominal
aggregates of ecosystems that that that
borrow from these these these ideas um
and then then create something something
that that takes as much the most we can
from from from our knowledge from from
what we've learned from work like
Catherine's but then uses our work as
well so so it's I know it's not a
perfect answer to what your what you're
saying what you're asking anyone else
yeah so how did so in in the traditional
systems how did they agreed to keep some
of that some of that area in this
communal land yeah I can't speak to that
in general I know in the in the Lacan
dome Mayan community and the mobile in
my community there are so there so there
are so okay they're different land
communities are managing that in
different ways we're where some are
working very community and you have a
communal land and they then they
actually have to ask permission from
every member of the community before
they can develop an area in the locking
dome
community they've actually partitioned
out the land at the family groups and
and so you have to ask within your
family if you're going to develop a
particular area so and I I would from
what I've what I've seen it's it's it's
somewhere in that in that right now in
some cases like in Belize some of that
communal land the government has said
you can't you can't touch it any more so
in some cases it's the community that's
doing it some cases family is doing some
cases as the government's doing there
are lots of different lots of different
ways of approaching at least that's what
I think that's what I've seen now how do
you design for it which I think what
you're really trying to get to
you know I don't know where you're
sharing yeah I don't that's that's the
million dollar question right um I I
don't know I mean I'm I I think I think
part of it is is the ethic that
you
to do with the small like small projects
working with kids I don't think it's
something that we're going to figure out
I think we're we're very educated in
them in the different direction right
now and so I think I think we have to
take a long vision towards it and and
just be trying to educate the kids about
it so that maybe their grandkids might
be thinking about it differently
unfortunately I think that that there's
a but then that at the same time you see
places like Seattle and and and Detroit
and Toronto and and Montreal that are
creating these communal lands where
where people can harvest from those
those lands and and then of course we
have government structures where with
lots of conservation and so it's a it's
a mixture I'm not sure I'm not sure
exactly what to do frankly but I think
we want to start small we don't want to
want to at least try with these small
steps this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu